franck galtier bonjour vous êtes
économiste spécialiste des marchés
agricoles dans les pays en développement
quels sont justement les pays les plus
concernés par ce risque de pénurie
alimentaire
alors bon bien sûr ce sont les pays qui
sont fortement importateur de blé ou de
maïs en provenance de russie ou
d'ukraine
donc certains pays dépend très fortement
de cette région là pour leur
approvisionnement par exemple le liban
l'egypte plus de 70% des céréales
importées par ces pays là viennent de
russie ou d'ukraine donc du coup
forcément ces pays-là risque même eu de
vivre un des difficultés
d'approvisionnement en tant qu un
problème vraiment quantitatif et puis il
ya d'autres pays qui ne sont pas
spécialement approvisionner
habituellement par la russie à l'ukraine
mais qui auront être frappé par les
augmentations de prix le prix des
céréales est également des huiles
végétales a très fortement augmenté
d'ailleurs il faut préciser que
l'augmentation avait commencé bien avant
la guerre en ukraine depuis le milieu de
l'année 2020 le prix des céréales blé
maïs et le prix des huiles végétales a
augmenté d'environ 80% donc à la veille
de 2,2 de la guerre en ukraine les prix
avaient déjà été déjà très élevé était
déjà sur une tendance ascendante alors
bien sûr la guerre à l'ukraine a encore
aggravé les choses et donc effectivement
il faut s'attendre à ce que à ce qu'il y
ait deux des difficultés importantes
dans pas mal de pays endémiques on vient
de le voir avec l'exemple de la france
c'est ce que d'autres pays producteurs
autre que l'ukraine et la russie
pourrait venir pallier les pénuries
alors ça c'est un discours qu'on entend
beaucoup depuis la crise en ukraine
notamment à l'échelle européenne
l'union européenne avait mis en place
toute une politique visant à avoir une
agriculture plus respectueuse
de la nature et de l'environnement moins
polluantes ça s'appelle form to fork ce
qui rend français voudrait dire de la
ferme à la fourchette et du coup cette
stratégie vise est vraiment avoir une
agréé afin de mettre un certain nombre
de contraintes environnementales sur la
production agricole de manière à réduire
les pollutions des sols des eaux des
aliments par exemple il ya ce qui était
prévu c'est de passer à l'horizon 2050 à
25 % des surfaces en agriculture
biologique dominion européenne ou encore
de réduire la consommation d'engrais
chimiques de 50% ou pas relevé et pardon
de 20% et de 50 % celle de celle de
pesticides donc ça c'étaient des mesures
qui auraient permis à la production
agricole européenne d'être beaucoup plus
respectueux de l'environnement et depuis
la crise en ukraine il ya un petit
discours qui monte qui est bien sûr
soutenu par le
laisser rallier des gens qui en tient qu
à terrassa disant qu'il faudrait
augmenter fortement la production dans
l'union européenne et que pour cela il
faudrait du coup mettre de côté toutes
ces contraintes environnementales que
ont souhaité mettre en place rapidement
fringale qui est certains économistes
mettent en garde contre de possibles
émeutes de la faim dans les pays en
développement
est-ce que c'est à redouter en effet
c'est quelque chose qui s'était produit
en 2008 quand il ya vu une augmentation
des prix d'une ampleur à peu près
similaire à celle qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et ce qu'ils s'étaient même
produit c'était une espèce de
mondialisation des émeutes urbaines
c'est à dire que certains pays voyant
que des émeutes urbaines s'était produit
dans d'autres pays
ça avait suscité du coup ça avait donné
l'idée dans d'autres pays aux gens
d'aller dans la rue pour protester
également en fait les gens protestent
contre une baisse très forte de leur
pouvoir d'achat ce qui a non seulement
l'augmentation du prix des aliments mais
aussi l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie
là en l'occurrence en arona à la fois le
nos plantations du prix d'énergie une
augmentation du prix des aliments mais
je voudrais revenir sur votre question
tout à l'heure sur l'idée d'augmenter la
production agricole comme réponse à
cette situation s'il vous plaît à mon
avis c'est vraiment pas une bonne idée
parce que
d'abord ça poserait effectivement comme
vous l'avez d'entre eux reportage un
grand nombre de contraintes
environnementales
sur la biodiversité et bien d'autres
choses mais surtout cette stratégie que
l'union européenne a commencé à amorcer
il à sortir d'un modèle de production
agricole qui repose sur les énergies
fossiles c'est à dire tous les engrais
de synthèse sont fabriqués à partir du
gaz naturel du ray par exemple et donc
du court en fait ce que révèle la crise
en ukraine c'est notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles y compris pour la
production agricole et du coup ce qu'est
ce qu'elle nous dit justement c'est
qu'au contraire il faut sortir de ce
modèle agricole si on veut sortir de
cette dépendance aux énergies fossiles
qui nous rend dépendante de pays
extérieurs comme la russie